donc tu veux aller à Stanford oui j'ai
presque eu un score parfait sur mes SAT
tu es un bon élève une Sierra
quelle est ta démarche excusez-moi Sierra
Burgess va se sentir parfois je donne
au seul adolescent qui n'est pas obsédé par les
regards à l'extérieur de toi  je me demande à quoi ressemble la
vie rejette Veronica Frodo est du Seigneur
des Anneaux tu penses à
Quasimodo Le Bossu de Notre DOM et
puis on te regarde ça me donne envie
de m'arracher les yeux
pense définitivement que je suis quelqu'un d'autre
ça s'appelle la pêche au chat et je suis à peu près
sûr que c'est illégal oh mon dieu Oh Veronica
Veronica c'est ce que je dois être à la hauteur
de tous les numéros de téléphone du monde il a
envoyé un texto au mien tu dois lui dire la
vérité
ce sont mes mots, il tombe amoureux de moi, pas
plus qu'un simple travail chaud
pensez-vous que vous savez que vous voulez sortir
avec moi ouais je sais que vous avez ressenti
tous vos cours alors je pense que nous pouvons nous
entraider mais  J'ai besoin d'un favori
tu es sûr que ça va marcher
non oh  mon Dieu bonne réponse Hé alors comment était
ta journée tu sais ce qui est bien c'est la
vidéo comme du tout peut-être devrions-nous
réessayer une autre fois
penses-tu que tu pourrais m'aimer tu es
exactement mon type
toute idée de ce que c'est que d'être une
adolescente  jusqu'à ce que, heureusement, vous sachiez que les
parties de l'artiste s'autorisent aux gens
[Musique]
oh la vérité, il n'est pas prêt
même si vous
attendez votre voix, elle est en fait plutôt
cool, c'est terrifiant, je sais que je suis
[Musique]
toi